[Musik]
einfach drauf
[Applaus]
einfach super verläuft oder nicht das
ist sehr angespannt die Situation für
mehr also rappen
von deinem Leben
das ist mein Vater er ist private
Detektiv nicht einer wie Matula oder
Magnum er ist echt um die Nächte ist der
Beruf ziemlich unspektakulär
okay eine Knarre hat er auch also mehr
als eine aber die lässt er schön zu
Hause
statt rum zu ballern heftet der
GPS-Sender am fremde Autos filmt
heimlich andere Leute und verfolgt sie
durchs Quartier für mich ist der der
beste Autofahrer auf der ganzen Welt
sein Job ist oft langweilig
tagelang sitzt mein Vater im
verdunkelten Auto observation nennt sich
das bei Laune hält in das Radio
schweizerörgeli ist sein Ding
[Musik]
wie war Detektiv ist der seit 32 Jahren
fast schon seit ich denken kann
eigentlich würde mein Vater sein
Geschäft gerne weiter vererben doch ich
war immer zu sehr mit Journalismus
beschäftigt vielleicht habe ich da was
verpasst als Journalist wollte ich schon
immer mal über ihn berichten aber
seriöse private Detektive wie er scheuen
Medien wie der Teufel das Weihwasser
googelt man ihn findet man weder Gesicht
noch Homepage Social Media braucht der
höchstens für seine Recherchen nun mit
73 kann es sich leisten nicht mehr im
Untergrund zu sein er will mich in die
Tricks seines Business einweihen
ich darf ihn aus Journalist mit der
Kamera begleiten doch diese muss immer
unauffällig bleiben
[Musik]
dürfen wir nicht erzielen vieles müssen
wir umkändlich machen ich als Sohn
könnte befangener kaum sein dieser Film
wird nicht objektiv aber vielleicht
finde ich heraus ob auch ich aus private
Detektiv taugen würde
[Musik]
der Tag beginnt mit einem Frühstück im
Auto und einem neuen Auftrag 80% der
Fälle meines Vaters kommen vom
Versicherungen für Sie beschattete
mutmaßliche Betrüger ja
überführen und Larven
Personen rumstehen nicht muss zahlen
wenn man wenn man sich überführen
wo Motivation gibt für überhaupt da dran
wir fahren zum Wohnort einer Frau sie
ist zu fast 100% krankgeschrieben und
erhält monatlich Geld von einer
Versicherung diese aber hat den Verdacht
dass die Frau trotzdem voll arbeitet in
einer Pizzeria der Privatdetektiv soll
dies beweisen
[Musik]
tschüss nach 20 Jahren Beziehung weiß
seine Lebenspartnerin dass sie ihn auf
der Jagd nicht stören darf jetzt
überwacht werden
im Jahr
hunderte Betrüger hat er schon überführt
für die Versicherungen ist er der
zuverlässige Mann für die Arbeit im Feld
heute hat er die Frau vier Stunden bei
der Arbeit beobachtet in ein paar Tagen
werden wir wiederkommen
am nächsten Morgen wartet ein anderer
Auftrag um 5 Uhr holt mich mein Vater zu
Hause ab
also
OMV heute geht's um ein
zwischenmenschliches Drama auch dies ein
Klassiker für ein private Detektiv eine
gescheiterte Beziehung der Ex-Freund
einer Frau will wissen wo sie heute
wohnt und wer ihr neuer Freund ist denn
der Mann selber darf sich der Frau nicht
mehr annähen deshalb engagiert er eine
private Detektiv ein heikler Auftrag
die zwei Personen Millionäre kennen
und man muss einfach aufpassen
dass man zum Beispiel beweisen
beschaffen Person
ja das geht halt die Kategorie
Auftrag von Privatpersonen und das ist
meistens
dass man sicher mit einer Vertrag
abschließen und nachher dass man
dumm das bezüglich hatte 120 Franken pro
Stunde meinen Vater zu engagieren kostet
schnell mal mehrere tausend Franken ich
fahre jetzt mal eine stören
ganz unauffällig verhalten
Batterie Gang ist auf deren Seite
Parkplatz
und zudem bin ich da relativ
unverdächtig denke nicht
die Umgebung machen wir unkenntlich und
Betroffene zu schützen
[Applaus]
so und
ja das ist wirklich so dass die Person
bleibt
die Person das Kleid wirklich so aus wie
bei dir erledigt
mein Vater will nun ein paar Stunden vor
dem Haus warten und die Frau beim
Rausgehen Filmen wobei er sie nur von
Fotos kennt bei der Größe
ein bisschen
[Musik]
da waren jetzt natürlich
sechs Partien
stundenlang aus dem Fahrzeug Filmen wird
mir klar dass unsere Jobs sehr ähnlich
sind als TV-Journalist ist es auch mein
Business andere Leute zu filmen
genau wie mein Vater suche auch ich als
Reporter immer ein kleines Abenteuer
definitiv illegal machen
die Arbeit von Reporter und private
Detektiv ist fast dieselbe sie gehen
raus sie filmen sie recherchieren und
holen Informationen ein
[Musik]
am Ende fertigen Sie daraus einen
Bericht und liefern diesen ab
bloß sind meine Berichte für ein
Publikum bestimmt normalerweise bin ich
im Bundeshaus im Vergleich zu private
Detektiven stehen
bundeshaus-journalisten in der
Öffentlichkeit verstecken geht nicht
0,0
manchmal denke ich mein Vater hätte auch
Journalist werden können oder ich
vielleicht private Detektiv
[Musik]
während zehn Jahren war er Präsident des
renommiertesten Berufsverbandes
Schweizer private Detektive volles
Engagement für den Job das hat er mir
vererbt auch mit 73 bleibt der
hartnäckig dran bis das Glück des
Tüchtigen in findend
[Musik]
okay
eigentlich
zu dem Auftrag aus
zurück im Büro zeigt er mir seine
Spezialwerkzeuge etwa eine ganze Reihe
Micro Kameras es gibt eine Minikamera in
einem Feuerzeug in einem Autoschlüssel
in einem falschen Kugelschreiber oder in
einer dicken Uhr und natürlich die
klassische knopflochkamera
in diesem Schrank lagert das
Geschäftsgeheimnis diese schwarzen
Klumpen sind GPS Tracker dankmagneten
haften diese an Autos sie haben eine
SIM-Karte und senden bis zu drei Monate
lang die Position von Fahrzeugen kann
mein Vater so jederzeit mitverfolgen
einen solchen Tracker wollen die heute
anbringen 5 Uhr morgens der
eifersüchtige Ex der Frau die wir vor
ihrem Haus gefilmt haben hat die Adresse
des mutmaßlichen neuen lovers geliefert
mein Vater soll rausfinden ob er
tatsächlich der neue Partner der Frau
ist
Musik aus
der tänger hat
jetzt mache ich nur klassische
ich bewundere den Draufgänger in meinem
Vater und den Nervenkitzel in seinem Job
den würde ich auch mögen
und
da kommt raus
müssen wir versuchen den Mann um 6 Uhr
morgens bei seiner Arbeit zu finden um
sein Auto dort mit einem Peilsender zu
versehen
[Musik]
wir warten ab der Mann wird wohl mit
einem Firmenfahrzeug das Gelände
verlassen dann wäre die Luft rein um an
seinem Auto den Tracker anzubringen
nicht nur eine Hundeleine auch eine
Getränkeflasche gehört in die Trickkiste
von private Detektiven als sogenannte
Legende also als Ausrede um unter fremde
Autos zu kriechen
ohne Fleiß kein Preis
das Ziel erreicht besser geht's nicht
das ist einfach so
ja
das ist im Grenzbereich rechtlich
straffahrzeug Verletzung von
Privatsphäre vor der Person aber
im autohockert ob es das mit cu-personen
oder Frau oder irgendwas
das GPS zeigt der Überwachte scheint
überhaupt nichts mit der Frau zu tun zu
haben ein Reinfall für den Auftraggeber
ein gelungener Auftrag für meinen Vater
am Auto von mutmaßlichen Liebhabern das
kann ja nicht legal sein zurück auf der
Redaktion will es der Journalist in mir
genauer wissen ich rufe verschiedene
Rechtsprofessoren an mit
Privatdetektiven kennt sich kaum jemand
aus denn diese bewegen sich gekonnt in
rechtlichen Grauzonen
schlussendlich aber finde ich
rechtsexpertinnen und Experten die sich
intensiv mit der Branche befasst haben
[Musik]
Persönlichkeitsverletzung also jetzt im
Sozialversicherungsrecht hat man genau
gerade das ausgesprochen genau
schwarze Bereich bewegt hat und das auch
weiterhin tut und auch von dem lebt ja
das mein Vater immer schön im grauen bis
dunkelgrauen Bereich operiert war mir
immer klar das aber praktisch alles
illegal sein soll ist nun trotzdem ein
Schock
ja
gesagt
irgendwie
Strassenverkehr ich weiß nicht was aber
das ständig im illegaler Bereich bewegen
das ist einfach
Mumpitz das ist ja zumutig wenn ihr so
beschuldigen stimmt einfach nicht also
du bist meistens
im grünen Bereich
illegal erworbene
eigentlich bestens wissen
von 1977 bis 1990 war mein Vater 13
Jahre lang bei der Kantonspolizei Bern
vom Dorf Polizisten hat es sich
hochgearbeitet zum Fahren bei der
spezialobservationsgruppe Milan hatte
etwa Drogendealer oder Einbrecherbanden
auffliegen lassen ich vermute
Ex-Polizisten fühlen sich ihr Leben lang
immer etwas im Recht
meinem Vater ist bewusst was droht wenn
er mit GPS-Geräten bei privaten
Aufträgen erwischt würde
dadurch
oder das Vergehen
okay
mein Vater ist ein Schlitzohr er dient
den rechtlichen Rahmen gekonnt bis zur
Schmerzgrenze ein moralischer Balanceakt
mir wäre dabei unwohl aus Journalist
muss oder darf ich mich an ein gewisses
arbeitetus halten in Vaters Fußstapfen
zu treten wäre zudem für mich ohne
Polizei Erfahrung ein ziemlich riskantes
Unterfangen
kaum eine Observation ohne gesetzliche
Grenzgänge
heute Film mein Vater erneut die Frau
die eigentlich nicht arbeiten kann
diesmal beim Pizza ausliefern
ja
ja hast ja noch gesehenen
eigentlich also sie macht der Betrug
weil
definitiv nein
auf Tri realisiere ich genau wie ich
geht mein Vater immer schön ans Limit 32
Jahre ging das gut er blieb unbemerkt
bis zu diesem Film
mit 73 möchte er langsam kürzer treten
ich hoffe ich bereite seine Karriere
nicht ein obruptes Ende denn sein
Gesicht ist nun kein Berufsgeheimnis
mehr für einen private Detektiv ist das
ein Problem
wird jetzt die
das hoffe ich nicht aber das kann
passieren ja
doch neue Erfahrung
Experiment ich werde immer private
Detektiv sie aber einfach völlig reden
ich selber werde wohl besser nicht
Privatdetektiv aber ich hoffe er kann es
trotz diesem Film bleiben wir haben
beide einen Job den wir lieben tauschen
möchte ich nicht umso mehr fasziniert er
mich mein Vater der private Detektiv
[Musik]